اشتباكات عنيفه تهز السودان مع انتهاء
الهدنه
النيتو يبدا اكبر مناوره جويه بتاريخه
وفاه رئيس الوزراء الايطالي الاسبق سيلفي
اوبرلسكوني
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
نبدا من السودان حيث شهدت العاصمه الخرطوم
بعد وقت قصير من انتهاء هدنه الاربع
والعشرين ساعه شهدت معارك عنيفه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وبحسب
الانباء الوارده من هناك سيطر الجيش على
محيط جسر الحلفايه في مدينه بحر شمال
الخرطوم كما تجدد القصف المدفعي تجاه نقاط
تمركز الدعم السريع في ام درمان الجيش
السوداني اوضح ان قوته قامت بعمليات تمشيط
لمناطق عده لافتا الى ان قوات الدعم
السريع تتخفى بالملابس المدنيه وتستخدم
سيارات مدنيه منهوبه في تحركاتها
في رساله يبدو انها موجهه الى موسكو
وبتنسيق الماني بدا حلف شمال الاطلسي
النيتو اليوم اكبر مناوره جويه في تاريخه
حيث ضمت نحو 250 طائره عسكريه من 25 دوله
عضوا في الحلف ودول اخرى بما فيها اليابان
والسويد الدوله المرشحه لعضويه النيتو
المناورات التي اطلق عليها اسم اردوغاندر
23 ستستمر حتى الثالث والعشرين من الشهر
الجاري ويشارك فيها ما يصل الى عشره الاف
شخص وتهدف الى تعزيز توافقيه التشغيل
والحمايه من الطائرات من دون طيار وصواريخ
كروز في حال وقوع هجوم على مدن او مطارات
او موانئ واقعه على اراضي الحلف
الى ايطاليا التي ودعت اليوم اشهر رئيس
وزراء في تاريخها وهو رئيس الوزراء الاسبق
سيلفيو بيرلس كوني الذي توفي عن عمر ناهز
السادسه والثمانين بعدما نقل الجمعه الى
مستشفى في ميلانو للخضوع لفحوص طبيه
مرتبطه باصابته بمرض سرطان الدم
الملياردير بيرلس كوني شغل منصب رئيس
الوزراء في ايطاليا ثلاث مرات بين عامي
94,11 وكان عضوا في مجلس الشيوخ ورئيسا
لحزبه اليميني فرصه ايطاليا وشريكا في
حكومه ميلوني كما هيمنه على الحياه العامه
لسنوات من خلال امبراطوريته الاعلاميه
والرياضيه
حادثه غريبه من نوعها شهدتها الاكوادور
وثقها مقطع فيديو انتشر بشكل كبير على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي المقطع اظهر
امراه متوفاه عادت للحياه خلال جنازتها
حيث لاحظ من حولها انها كانت تتنفس بصعوبه
داخل نعشها السيده صاحبه 76 عاما كانت
ادخلت الى المستشفى جراء اصابتها بجلطه
دماغيه ثم توقف قلبها ما دفع الطبيب
المناوب لتاكيد وفاتها الامر الذي دفع
اداره المستشفى للتحقيق بالحادثه وتقديم
تقرير طبي لتحديد المسؤول عن اصدار شهاده
الوفاه الخاطئه
خبرنا الاخير من كوريا الجنوبيه حيث القت
الشرطه القبض على بريطانيه كان يتسلق اعلى
ناطحه سحاب في البلاد وهي برج من دون اذن
وبلا معدات امان موظفوا البرج ابلغوا عن
المغامر البريطاني الذي اجبر على التوقف
عن التسلق بعد وصوله الى الطابق الثالث
والسبعين فيما اكدت الشرطه انه يخضع حاليا
للاستجواب في مركز امني في العاصمه سول
وكان البرج ذاته شهد تسلقا غير قانوني من
قبل الفرنسي
الملقب بالرجل العنكبوت قبل خمسه اعوام
قبل القاء القبض عليه وسجنه